-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
Let's get to the news.
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki said
in a briefing yesterday
that there are about 100
American citizens
still in Afghanistan,
though Psaki stressed they're
doing everything in their power
to move on to the next question.
Pro-Trump protesters gathered
in New Jersey yesterday
as President Biden surveyed
storm damage from Hurricane Ida.
Okay, but Trump is gone,
so what you guys are
is pro storm damage.
After the Taliban announced a
new all-male interim government
in Afghanistan yesterday,
the State Department
released a statement
voicing concern
over the lack of women.
Um, you know that's kind of
their whole deal, right?
It's like walking
into a KKK meeting
and saying, "Wow!
Just white guys? Okay."
Today was Senator
Bernie Sanders' 80th birthday.
Happy birthday, Bernie.
I would have gotten you
something,
but then I would've had to
get it for everybody.
A 21-foot statue of Confederate
general Robert E. Lee
was taken down today
in Virginia,
but only because
they finally finished
their 22-foot statue of him.
A video recently gained
attention on social media
showing Rudy Giuliani shaving
at a table
in an airport restaurant.
And it's even worse
than it sounds
because he was shaving
his bikini line.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
A video showed Rudy Giuliani
shaving at a restaurant table
in JFK airport.
To be fair, he thought
he was at LaGuardia.
We had some discussion.
We caught a little flak, Baze,
from some people here
who noted that happened
a long time ago.
I was like all --
That was last week.
But come on, guys.
I know we're going back in time
a little bit,
but you're gonna let that happen
on our hiatus
and we're just never gonna
talk about it?
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The host of the children's show
"Blue's Clues," Steve Burns,
released a video yesterday in
honor of its 25th anniversary,
but this is weird --
just to remind everyone that
Blue would be long dead by now.
[ Laughter ]
It must be nice to be Ian,
sitting alone in your apartment.
You go say it.
I just write it.
You say it!
And finally,
customs officials in Texas
recently fined a man $500 after
he allegedly tried to smuggle
more than 300 pounds of bologna
and ham over the border.
It was a tough day
for the smuggler,
but a career day
for the drug-sniffing dogs.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.